in the last video we visualized an
ethane molecule with a newman projection
what i want to do in this video is show
that you can really visualize
longer chains or or even we'll see in
future videos even a cyclical ring-based
carbon molecules with newman projections
as well and i guess the next most
complex
molecule to study would be butane
butane we could do propane but
butane will be interesting this was
ethane right here butane will have four
carbons and if i were to draw it in kind
of a ball and as a ball and stick model
it would look like something like this
so this would be one carbon right there
then you would have another carbon right
over there and another carbon
right over there and then you would have
your fourth carbon and then your
hydrogens you would have a hydrogen
coming out like this like that
and then up like that this guy would
have two hydrogens that would stick out
like that this guy would have two
hydrogens that stick out like that and
then finally this guy will also have
three hydrogens the ch3
just like that now
if we try to draw a newman projection
here's like well you know what do you
consider the front or the back carbon
and all of that and you actually can
pick and what what's interesting in a
butane molecule is if you pick
if you pick this guy if you pick so this
is the one two three four carbons if you
pick the two carbon as our front and our
three carbon as our back and then we
view this carbon the ch3 is kind of one
of the add-ons onto that carbon you can
then do a newman projection so let's try
to do this so this will be the front one
so we'll put this carbon in the front
and we'll put this carbon over here
we'll put this carbon over here
in the
in the back and before i even drew the
new draw the newman projection let me
redraw this but i'm just going to draw
this instead of with the hydrogens the
bonds explicitly defined i'm just going
to call this a ch3 so let me re
let me redraw this so i'll do this in
orange so you have this carbon
i'll do this kind of as a modified ball
and stick
so that carbon it has a hydrogen
it has
that hydrogen and that hydrogen and
instead of drawing this out i'm going to
just draw this whole thing
this whole thing right here and i'll do
it in
i'll do it in magenta i'm going to draw
this whole thing as just a ch3
so i'm going to draw this whole thing as
just a ch3 so i'll draw it really big
because it's not just one atom it's four
atoms so this is our ch3
and well to do ball and stick everything
really should be a ball so i'll draw a
ball there ball there so that's our
carbon number two and then it has this
bond it has this bond over here
to this carbon number three
which when we do our newman projection
we'll put in the back
so our carbon number three is like that
and then the carbon number three it has
two hydrogens and then it has this
it has this you can kind of view it as
this methyl group attached to it if you
want it has this ch
it has this ch3
attached to it right there so i'll do
the ch3 i'll do it in this blue color
and so we could draw it like this so the
ch3
is coming off
so i'll draw it really big because it's
not just one atom
so it's a
ch3 and then you have your two hydrogens
and then sorry you have your two
hydrogens down here so let me be very
clear here so let me
this this hydrogen that hydrogen that's
that hydrogen and that hydrogen this
thing here is that thing there that big
ball right there is this whole ball and
then let me find a i'll do green this
hydrogen and this hydrogen is
that height
this hydrogen
and this hydrogen and when you look at
it this way now you say oh now i can see
how i would draw a newman projection i
put this in the front then the back i
treat this whole part of the molecule as
just a group if you will it is a group
so let's do the newman projection here
and we can think about where it's most
stable so the way i've drawn it right
here
so you have your c i'll do this as the
front this carbon 2 is going to be the
front molecule so you have this ch
you have the ch3 group
going down and then you have these two
hydrogens
you have these two hydrogens hydrogen
and hydrogen that's the front and in the
back you have this blue one you can
imagine in the front if we want to maybe
i'll do a little small orange thing to
show this is the orange carbon and then
the blue carbon is going to be in the
back
the blue carbon is in the back draw it
like this
so that's my blue carbon and the way
we've done it here we have a
ch3
pointing straight up and then we have
our two hydrogens we have our
two hydrogens now just like we talked
about in the first video on newman
projections all of these groups have
these hydrogens have electron clouds
around them this whole ch3 group has a
larger electron cloud around it it's a
carbon atom plus hydrogens they all want
to get away from each other the ch3 is
even a bigger molecule so to some degree
it's going to play a bigger role in
whether something is a higher or lower
potential energy or whether it's wound
or not so i guess the most obvious or
maybe it's not obvious but the ch3 group
since they they have the biggest
electron crowd they're kind of crowding
the molecule the this ch3 group and this
ch3 grouper they're going to get as far
away from each other as possible so the
way we did this it looks kind of like
our staggered conformation but when
we're dealing it with actual methyl
groups that are separated as far as they
can from each other we call this the
anti-conformation
we call this the anti-conformation right
here
anti-conformation
and if we think about dihedral angles
between the two methyl groups the
dihedral angle here
the dihedral angle here is 180 degrees
180 degrees
dihedral angle and this is the lowest
lowest potential energy
potential energy
or the most stable
and that confuses you when i talk about
lowest potential energy just think about
it a rock on the ground has a lower
potential energy than a rock that is 50
feet in the air a rock on the ground is
also more stable it's less likely to do
something something 50 feet in the air
maybe if you nudge it a little bit it'll
fall off the cliff or wherever it is or
maybe it's already falling who knows
it's going to move when you have higher
potential android or it takes very
little for it to release energy but when
you have lower potential energy you're
more stable so this is the most stable
conformation now what are the other
situations you could do here well you
could keep rotating these let's say
let's say you rotated the back the back
carbon around clockwise what are the
other conformations we could get and so
let me just
let me just draw the front portion right
here so you have your ch3
you have your ch3 and then you have your
two hydrogens
hydrogen
and hydrogen and let me copy and paste
this
so there's two other real i mean there's
everything in between but these are the
ones that are interesting
control copy and then let me let me copy
it
copy and then paste
so i'll draw i'll actually draw three of
these
so then you have that
and then let me paste it one more time
then you have that so these obviously
this would be the front the front carbon
and also in every situation if i want i
could make it a little orange dot to
show that that's the front carbon and
then let me draw the back carbon i
should have copied and pasted this as
well so you have your back carbon in
every situation now if we were to rotate
this if we were to rotate this character
by 60 degrees if we were to rotate
actually if we rotate the back by 60
degrees what would it look like
well then we would have
we would have this hydrogen
would move up there
so then you would have
this hydrogen actually if we were to
move it by 120 degrees i should say this
would be 60 and then another 120 degrees
so this hydrogen would go up there
this hydrogen
would go up there this methyl group
would now be over here
and then
this hydrogen would go over here
so we've just rotated the whole thing by
120 degrees we've rotated by 120 degrees
now this conformation this was called
the anti-conformation it's the most
stable because the carbon the methyl
groups are as far away from each other
as possible this right here is called
the gauche conformation
the gauche conformation let me do this
in a different
this is the gauche
conformation
and you can view this as the second most
stable at least the methyls are
staggered they're not directly behind
each other so here the methyls are as
far apart from each other as possible if
you look at the ball and stick model i
actually drew it in that conformation
right here they're as far apart from
each other if you were to flip this
molecule if you were to flip it this
methyl would get closer to this methyl
and their electron clouds would start to
crowd each other so in this situation
this is anti-most stable if you rotate a
little bit they'll get a little bit
closer but they'll still be staggered
you get the gauche conformation now if
we rotate this
if we rotate the back guy now 60 degrees
60 degrees clockwise so if we rotate it
just 60 degrees clockwise what's going
to happen
what's going to happen well then you're
going to have an eclipsed conformation
where the carbons are directly but where
the the methyl groups are directly
behind each other
and that's going to be your least stable
situation
right so you would have your you would
have this guy and i'll draw it slightly
so you'd have this guy you know ch3
there and then you would have your
hydrogens that are
right behind each other so a hydrogen
and a hydrogen
so in this situation where eclipse this
is the least stable
least stable and also the most potential
energy and then if we were to go another
60 degrees from this then we go to
another gauche conformation if you
rotate this another 60 degrees then
you'd have a ch3 here and then you would
have this hydrogen would be up here and
then this hydrogen here so this is
staggered the ch the the methyl groups
are at least they're not directly behind
each other but they're not as far as
they could be if we were to rotate
another 120 degrees and get to the
anti-conformation so this one right here
is also a gauche conformation so
hopefully you understand now that if you
just have to pick two carbons and then
you can if there's kind of big things
attached to each of those carbons you
can just represent them as groups and
when you do that you can really use a
newman projection for any part of a a a
molecule and when you do that you can
start to think about how it can rotate
and what parts or what what versions of
it will be more or less stable